[Musique]
tout de suite retrouver l'actualité de
la semaine retour en image sur les
principaux événements du
département le premier marché des
producteurs a été organisé ce jeudi 4
août à Saint-Pierre l'occasion pour
Nassima nandar président du département
et Serge oirot conseiller départemental
en charge de l'agriculture de rappeler
les objectifs de ces rendez-vous
voilà pays que nous défendent le
vice-président avec nous parce que ça
c'est la réunion que nousim et
l'agriculture nous monsieur là écris la
cour pour les B carré a le 1 ah ou moi
je suis nous sommes une ferme auberge
nous faisons du canard surtout ça permet
à des petits producteurs comme nous de
vendre leurs produits sans passer par le
marché où il faut payent la place tout
ça bah pour moi je trouve que c'est
c'est excellent c'est bon je fais le
marché for à Saint-Joseph mais là c'est
un autre marché pour moi je vois
beaucoup plus de monde nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans un dispositif qui est
en vigueur qui a été actionné et avec le
FAD l'objectif c'est de pouvoir
véritablement donner tous les moyens
financiers pour nos agriculteurs tant au
niveau de l'accompagnement dans le
transfert de connaissance l'encadrement
technique que sur les investissements
puisque les dispositifs qui sont
actionnés aujourd'hui concernent les
investissements en matière de bâtiments
d'élevage de structure de serre sur la
mécanisation sur l'amélioration du
foncier agricole et nous les invitons
aujourd'hui à présenter leur dossier à
s'adresser aux différents services
instructeurs pour V blement libérer les
fonds qui sont mis à leur disposition le
prochain marché pays se déroulera à
l'espace redley à Saint-Denis le 13 août
2016 durant les vacances scolaires
Mascarin jardin botanique de la Réunion
propose divers ateliers et animations
pour les petits alors les ateliers
marmaille depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois proposent diverses actions en
direction de la valorisation de
l'identité réonnaise son patrimoine son
sa culture son identité et c'est vrai
qu'on prend plaisir à aller se balader
de jardin botanique en
sentiers plein de petites actions comme
ça qui font en sorte d'apporter un socle
où les enfants peuvent s'approprier leur
environnement pour pouvoir se construire
et à leur tour apporter des choses à à
cette à ce beau territoire rionnais
c'est donc l'année internationale des
légumineuses on va essayer de leur faire
découvrir les trésors de ces plantes
donc on a prévu une grande chasse au
trésors pour leur faire découvrir les
légumineuses du jardin et faire un focus
sur les légumineuses les grains là on a
fait on a fait des
petits avec des feuillesprès on
attaché une trés on découvre des plantes
on fait plein de choses un atelier
ludique qui sensibilise les enfants à la
diversité des espèces comestibles qui
ont marqué la vie des
Ronn et retrouvons maintenant le
magazine de la
semaine vous les avez sûrement déjà
croisés sur nos route c'est fameux car
jaune qui Assur les liaisons
interurbaines mais beaucoup plus rare il
se peut que vous trouviez au volant de
ces autobus non pas un conducteur mais
une conductrice rosem est la seule femme
de son entreprise à exercer ce métier
rencontre mon service avec mon collègue
donc ben directement la gare routière
pour commencer la journée quoiessour un
J voilà pour avoir quoi comme un B
contact les gens avoir le sourire être
patient comme j'aime j'aime aussi être
sur la route donc voilà quoi vous voyez
faire un autre métier non honnêtement
non c'est pour
arrêter directement il pense que le
chômage m assise quoi c'est quoi c'est
presque une passion finalement oui ça
devient une passion à la à la don mais
sinon ça il faut aimer il faut aimer il
faut c'est pas dès le départ il viennent
avoir le
permis en disant oui on est là le permis
non c'est pas c'est pas que ça il faut
aimer rouler il faut aimer avoir le
contact avec les personnes donc ben
voilà
[Musique]
quoi à 37 ans rosem conduit depuis plus
de 6 ans ses autocars aujourd'hui c'est
au volant de ce car jaune long de 13 m
que ce petit bout de femme va assurer la
liaison avec le sud de
[Musique]
lî il y a pas de distinction nous chez
nous dans dans dans le milieu du
transport il y a pas de distinction
homme femme donc elle a elle a le même
planning elle fait les mêmes services
elle a elle a les mêmes problématiques
que que que peuvent avoir les hommes
dans dans ce métier là les mêmes
contraintes mais elle les assume comme
si comme si c'était c'était un homme
donc et c'est très c'est c'est
remarquable c'est c'est c'est
remarquable pour une femme aujourd'hui
d'exercer ce métier
là il est pareil que nous est pareil pas
de souci conduit pareil donc d'accord
est comme une voiture madame un monsieur
plart conduit presque pareil donc
sécurité avant toute façonçon les
formations il dit il dit pour nous il
dit pour la dame il dit pour toute façon
les formations c'est pour les mix pour
tout donc rosem est la seule femme parmi
les 43 conducteurs de la société pour
laquelle elle travaille mais pas de
jugement cette conductrice a pris ici
toute sa place super bien super bien
franchement super bien du moment on a
l'entends Le respect avant tout donc mes
collègues beaucoup
qu'on un petit truc qui va pas et voilà
quoi moi pousse à les personnes qui sont
d'ailleurs dans mon entreprise surtout
au niveau des femmes que comme je suis
la seule essaie de revenir vers carun
quoi parce que je suis la seule donc
voilà
do
[Musique]